[Music]
i'm beryl and this week i'm looking at
ice cream
i'm wearing my uh cherries in honor of
the ice cream sundae i'm about to make
okay i'm ready i haven't made an ice
cream sundae in
i don't even know how long fun fact do
you know why an ice cream sundae is
called a sundae
in the 1800s there were a lot of laws
that were restricting what could and
could not be sold on sundays so things
like alcohol fell under that but also
carbonated beverages like soda
all right two flavors
so drugstores to get around this on
sundays instead of selling ice cream
floats would just sell ice cream and put
syrup on top and they called it a sunday
because it was sold on sundays
cheeky huh
add a little chocolate
[Music]
an ice cream in america it's beloved
but it's common pretty much everywhere
around the world it'll have different
variations it's not always made out of
frozen milk sometimes it's ice sometimes
it includes noodles
so
in celebration of arguably the most
beloved type of dessert out there i
spoke to seven people in seven countries
to see the different iterations of ice
cream around the world
so this
is the ice cream episode
[Music]
yum
it's so good
per usual in making this episode i've
decided two things one my definition of
ice cream is fluid this is thematic you
know
and two nothing can come from the frozen
foods aisle
for all the ice creams that i missed and
all the flavors i didn't talk about let
me know in the comments what ice cream
is like where you live and what your
favorite flavor is i'm also curious
about like ice pops or ice cream cones
from the frozen aisle in the supermarket
i think that could be really interesting
to see the different ones around the
world i don't know let me know what you
think
anyway let the ice cream social begin
i'll be here
finishing this sunday
this ice cream is special because it
coats a lot of things that are not found
around the world it's only
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're starting in the philippines with
one of the most colorful ice cream
concoctions out there
[Music]
hello i hindi ice cream sundae
ice cream sundae is just ice cream
itself anghalo halo literally means in
english mix mix
so meron shatte butter banana
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so if you have a joyful heart colorful
denial puja
next up germany because this ice cream
presentation made me smile
spaghetti ice hockey farm seed austria
until spaghetti
and
[Music]
[Music]
b in oaxaca mexico they make their ice
cream using wooden barrels and the
process is mesmerizing
[Music]
no problem
[Music]
is
you can't talk about ice cream without
including italy but we decided to look
at granite it's an ice cream adjacent
cold treat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this ice cream features a local fruit
that makes it very particular to south
africa
[Music]
so my ice cream we don't need machine
you don't need a lot of things just your
hands my name is talinchon manguanya i'm
from zimbabwe i'm going to make an
african-style ice cream this one it's
got an african plant on it and then a
mass
almost is a milk that comes straight
from the cow and then it's hundred
percent pure no eating i'm gonna be
using num num plants same like berries
i like them because they have a nice
flavor i'll use half almost and then
i'll take sugar cream and then i'll mix
it
i'll take my normal berries crush them
and put them inside my mixture
take an empty bag pour my mixture inside
the bag i'll take another aimed peg put
some ice under then i'll shake it for 10
minutes
after 10 minutes the ice cream will be
done
once you take it you'll be able to tell
this is an african flavor
as for me i can recommend this ice cream
because fruits they are good and then
it's easy to make
[Music]
in turkey the ice cream is stretchy so i
had to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and finally in iran we're looking at a
dessert that includes noodles and ice
cream in a very special combination
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
ice cream may seem like a superficial
topic you know the idea that people
around the world all like ice cream
seems kind of obvious
but if you really look at it
food is this amazing equalizer it
doesn't matter where you are who you are
you have something in common with
somebody on the other side of the world
because of something so simple in this
case as a dessert
and
i don't know there's it's just something
about that just makes me feel good and
that's why i make this series and i hope
that that's what you're getting out of
it too ice cream you scream we all
scream for ice cream
sorry
man
ice informs from spaghetti become this
is naturally
[Music]
[Music]
this ice cream is so special because
it's your own you choose your own flavor
your own thing for you it's pure ice
cream
you